[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's do it
let's do what it's yeah I mean we were
but yesterday but we're keeping the
train going because now we're further
along in the story yes I feel like I
just skipped everything what's up good
morning everyone happy Thursday a Persia
here
David joining me today we had max on
board yesterday but now David is taking
over he has also been playing and he's
made it yeah you know pretty far in yeah
a new arc we were playing a the first
arc yesterday you guys play the same
soccer yeah yeah yeah and now we're
moving on now we are in the freezer saga
yeah and you can play as Vegeta which is
cool I have to say like in the beginning
of the game I was kind of not not
supported I was having fun but like
I'm not a fan of kid Goku or kicking
just like and having you know Goku just
not even though okay okay yet so it was
like it's kind of we didn't have a lot
of stuff going on and now that I'm like
I'm walking super moves so we're kind of
like in the middle of it right now where
he's uh he's fighting all the bruises
cronies they're all Scouters you know I
ran into you friended Oreo earlier he's
super duper day you beat tutorial so
that's why he never came back
which can only mean freezes holding on
to the Dragon Balls you obtained so far
you reason will not get his dirty hands
on all of them I'll make sure of it I've
already found one myself and the others
are as good as mine alright so this is
my first fight of the day let's see how
I
Kevin Smith asks in the chat any
differences you've noticed from the Xbox
one X and the pro so I can only speak
for the 1x exam and played on the pro
but it's it's nice I mean the game
itself is a little but I will say but
it's like it's like right now this I
mean despite its like exhilarating won't
really like sometimes it will only cut
scenes and stuff but when it comes to
actually playing it
at this point I feel like I feel like
ps4 1x are it's like negligible
difference and it's more of like if
you're playing on a base and there's
also already gonna be some k1 patches
with game comes out tomorrow for
everyone wondering I would expect there
to be some things ironed out already
from what we're seeing now yeah thanks
for joining us welcome back to all the
familiar faces we're seeing Brandon
whatup also silly back in the chat
Alex says I want this team so bad well
tomorrow tomorrow homie but you don't
seem to realize the mistake you've just
made you have awakened my true power
you've got quite a sense of humor
go on show me your power I love this
part about Dragon Ball it's so
melodramatic prepare to be amazed by my
glorious transformation glorious it's
like this is like a master class in
roasting 101 that's all they do 90% of
the fights are just then talking [ __ ]
here big boy animation says did they
release it for PC yes it is gonna be
available on PC via Steam so Xbox
Playstation and PC are getting the list
[Music]
you guys are allowed to do different
combos yeah find out sue on you can
unlock more combos in like a skill tree
usually you can add different players to
it by mixing up your buttons or adding
super moves and things like that
oh he passed out did it oh he passed I'm
afraid I can't let you die just yet I
still have a lot to ask you
ominous
raxil with interesting heavy-hitting
questions already he said so was all or
or she not sure so with all honesty is
the game of that fun or does it turn out
to be repetitive it's both
oh yeah it's repetitive because it's an
open RPG so you are going to be doing
things like fetch quests you know you're
gonna be foraging fishing leveling up
skills chasing a bunch of these orbs in
the air and the combat doesn't really
change it's still just normal fighting
so in that sense it is repetitive but is
it fun develops because you have to
unlock those other abilities over time
yes I think that the beginning is very
slow I will say I didn't have a lot of
fun for sour I'm having way more fun now
yeah my gratitude it pains me that most
of my children on this planet have
fallen victim to such vile invaders I
had no idea the Dragon Balls the very
symbols of namekian wisdom and power
could cause such strife Oh welcome to
the stream I could borrow the wine in
here it's kind of important you know
like could I uh could I borrow just to
prevent relating everyone would you be
immortal here's to return to Earth what
Dragon Balls yeah yeah piccolo bro oh
yeah I remember hearing about one coming
to earth in order to flee some sort of
crisis here on Namek it must have been
Coty's child truthfully I'm surprised
the child was able to survive the
journey case goes can y'all take my xeni
now
he was a gifted member of the dragon
clan the creators of the Dragon Balls
how is it he met his end did he die of
natural causes
or was he killed he was killed by
someone here on Namek a Saiyan named
Vegeta
I would like to yeah I wouldn't be so
willing through a lot of embarrassing
moments we've Brian just really snare
Friday it officially releases Friday but
if you're in the West Coast you can play
you are able to skip dialogue Kevin yes
you are I'm not because we're recording
this in for one of our walkthroughs
we're gonna have a bunch of walkthroughs
for this whole game on our game spot
gameplay channel that you guys can check
out and a lot of people do kind of want
that story even though the story is very
well known there's nothing really like
new and different that's the cool thing
about this game I think because even for
people who aren't familiar with the
story it's a good way to catch up like
myself like I'm not super familiar the
whole story haven't seen it from the
beginning but I've seen later episodes
and like random movies come out in like
are shown in like theater like select
theory sometimes absolutely it's nice
absolutely I was um I actually started
so I wasn't a lot of watch attraction
but I was it was it was started with the
Buu saga which is and all of this stuff
the Frieza saw I see in the Android saga
trick I learned through playing shoot
acai dragon ball z budokai Guan vidiq I
- we'll just have to do what we can
I'll keep the Dragon Ball and I'll guard
it with my life
are you
I must say you seem to possess a great
deal of strength for not much of it lies
dormant and unrealized I brought a
friend of mine here to see you I bet
he's got more untapped power than me
please bring him here okay
I'll be right back with him let's go
let's do it wait here did a potential
that dragon was a lot bigger than I
thought it was yeah right you just kind
of see a lot of skipping yeah that was I
was skipping it whenever I saw a
sentence and to keep it a little
self-contained you could always read it
that's what I loved about some of those
subtitles it's heading straight for us
do you do you think it's crawling on his
way back
he attacked the village but he didn't
find the Dragonball Krillin is kind of
like the gears of work Harline was just
like you always get always get rekt at
some point
would you forget oh this part kind of
bugs me where they do such good voice
acting and then some of these at some
point they just stop doing the voice
acting and it's just like little phrase
like yes kid go on I don't care for I
actually submitted yesterday and only
got like 12 likes but I don't got that
Twitter clout yeah the fact that I got
like I think like 15 or 16 I was like oh
yeah if people agree because I just
wrote it I was like kid go home to loser
because he is though but adult Gohan and
teen Gohan are so badass and they're
like my favorite which is weird I know a
lot of people love go do a lot of people
love the cheetah or trunks but I'm okay
that's fair I mean when we were playing
yesterday in kind of like I have all
this power yet it's so scared of
everything go on so but it's fine I
think you know when we were children
you're probably the same way I want to
fight so I'm skipping some of the side
quests for now all the blue stuff that
you see flashing in the air there's like
these beams of light those are y'all
just chill do you think I got this
Dragon Ball I love dude this is like
that's just the stuff for most of you
that's like it doesn't make sense when
there
yes that was the Dragon Ball Vegeta he
chucked it like Tesla that was a loud
internal yeah you're right you're right
all right thank you fighting Frieza yeah
he's not gonna beat Frieza though so my
my how impressed I am is has a cap on it
at the moment
yes you can see like the frame drops a
little bit sometimes the tells customer
it's a vegeta Frieza better start better
get scared man beat it how it how's it
going welcome to the stream what a hole
what up people spend their lives
searching for all seven he just found
five out of seven Super Saiyans Totally
Rad where to kid go on that was sarcasm
yeah super sighs man I keep the seven he
he he sucked for sure
but when when Gohan like reveals that he
was actually the gold warrior that
turned like that Simon we're currently
playing on xbox yesterday stream was on
ps4 so if you guys kind of want to
compare both you can always check out
yesterday he'd be like that sometimes
it'd be like that it pains me to say but
it appears Saiyans are capable of more
than I initially thought
they seemed to grow stronger with each
battle they managed to survive doesn't
kill you me can't hope to be superior
level of course still hit mic proof
prudent to finally rid myself of them
once and for all it would be quite
bothersome if I had to deal with a Super
Saiyan it seems it may be time to call
the ginyu force oh the freakin kid new
for us cleave 1x and is the 1x
[Laughter]
they have no respect for these dragon
mother scatter them on the floor this is
what you get Frieza
your dragon balls are finally mine now
that I have these and the one that I hid
under water that leaves just one to
collect then I'll have all seven you
should have like a a bank account or
something to put these in he's just
leaving them out oh no
[Music]
it's gonna get way stronger than me when
he beats guru Y Z or Namek he's holding
the very last Dragonball as well
wait what I thought Gohan at the last
no no no he's got oh wait oh no cuz
Vegeta thinks he still has the wandering
through in the lake that's the has to be
it but yeah you're right you're like I'm
just looking for something human right
now
alright and I don't know if I respect
that as someone who's short expecting
the short characters like this to make
it a new save so this will be my stream
safe so I can kind of I can go through
the cutscenes a little faster so you get
to freak out
yes very fast warden was so focused on
my increase in power wearing a Scouter
that's a nice dragon ball you've got
yourself there doing something stupid
like running away well well thanks to
your foolish actions if you don't give
me the location of the Dragon Balls you
know just about to make a comment about
how like fabulous helix Road
it's formed before it is like so when
they're glowing red it took me a while
to realize this but like you can not the
way that he looked red earlier that was
red he was like armored but when he was
like in the red flame that's just him
try to get any curious about that I knew
that red meant there was some sort of
armor property but I didn't notice it
was like the charge hub zarab on
Instagram present reality trap nuts on
this looks a little choppy
I felt like yesterday there was a little
left to die on the ps4 version but I
also don't think it was a strenuous over
the battle yeah definitely
[Music]
Vegeta got catfished ding I think the
level you're seeing is like the player
level not like the characters however I
think so let me see what if it was what
he was talking about if it was the level
on the bottom I'm like my bar yeah add
the flying sound effect because it's
like literally one frame of him just
like I have to hide it and while I'm in
the sky no no not a cloud he's a kid he
should be great at hiding
got him that dragon ball was hidden
perfectly it's alright mostly you guys
know the story I think I just want to
fight Frieza wish this was on switch
whoo this would be an intense game Chris
whips it would be a little intense for
the switch
unless you're playing a doctor or
something what did you see that alien I
think you could be on that thing for
sure for sure you fools
oh there we go I knew someone was gonna
call you out you want to get to the
Frieza fight that's why David's a
patient you know he spent all of his
patients stuck on the BART before Phil
that's out the window yeah we're gonna
if you all want the dialogue and
everything we're gonna be uploading the
full walkthrough small this starting
today so you guys can check all of that
out with the hole cut scenes and
dialogue and Luke and all their glory
y'all don't like it you can follow me on
Twitter and then I need the follower
send me all your complaints yeah you're
right Tokyo they do have Witcher 3 on
the switch so I guess it wouldn't be too
far out of the realm of possibility what
are you talking about you won't talk
I'll just have to make men that threat
that would definitely make me talk what
do you think of great power it comes
with great responsibility obviously it
excites me Felix
it's absolutely nothing you want to be
scared for oh they want you to be
wholesome David re to defeat Frieza to
bring you back to life to eradicate evil
oh they're all correct no they're not
they're all correct we would fail does
this lead up to super great questions I
don't know I know for sure they're gonna
include the Buu saga goes in the super
that would be tight if it doesn't you
know yeah it could be potential DLC
yeah DLC has opened the realm of every
possibility although I didn't hear
something where they said totally huse
brand-new that would be great I love
these carrying those dragon ball away
the football Jonah's gear skinny B other
characters yes so in the main line
campaign it will choose the character
for you you can't change your party but
in between arcs there are intermissions
that's like free play and you can you
can swap your team and play whoever you
want and add where everyone on your
party only one way to beat them and
that's to give me the ball so I can wish
for immortality
but if we do this then we came all the
way out here for nothing the Dragon
Balls grant the use of three wishes I
don't get my wish they kiss her goodbye
okay fine
follow us
all right we are on a just like
speedboat right now trying to escape the
keyboards these guys are coming in hot
cliff do you think Crillon will get hair
later makes him he doesn't get here
later I wasn't sure if they were
actually gonna do the whole thing like
right off the jump but he did so I don't
even know that much about Geronimo but I
know about Guinea forest I know about
this pose the traitorous Vegeta has to
make him suffer for his crime and then
bring him to me and consider it done
already we have Vegeta's location he's a
scary so what's the rating GameSpot uh
you'd have to check her check our review
when he goes up if it's already up I'm
not sure if we've had enough time with
the game yet we're taking the Dragon
Ball
[Music]
you know what my power level is so the
Year already passed we were playing
yesterday they were like oh my god
they'll be here in like a year's years
for sure and we are here now they were
saying a year because it was what it was
piccolo and Gohan training right like in
the meanwhile yeah Goku is dead he's
alive now again already it's much like
real life if I'm not mistaken that's one
of the Dragon Balls isn't it damn good
eye bro I really thought the Dragon
Balls are smaller than Sona Mickey
injectables are making Dragon Ball so
much so they're all yeah so they're I'm
playing in amic in the dark
[Laughter]
sorry and then the pan down I chose your
fight yeah being before the battle title
was even gone already
level 25 hmm see whenever I play RPGs
I purposely like over level just because
I don't want to struggle do you feel
like the leveling system in this is
pretty much like that you ever feel like
oh let me go level up a bit before
hundred percent um I'm just not doing it
obviously for the sake of for the stream
and like mainlining the footage is
faster but absolutely if you're gonna
play this game you should take your time
explore a bit do as many of the side
quests it's just it's an awful
experience that way and the fights end
up being a little easier to those levels
the new character blonde you is
apparently a former member of beginning
of chorus have you checked that out at
all I know it's a pre-order bonus
apparently she has like a tree and like
a special training mode or something
like that
oh yeah I saw that
yeah Vanya was me receive official
Oh ding that angles so weird veining
Fiat says how's the game until now it's
good I like it a lot more my second day
than I did my first air
it starts off a little slow but that's
let's see just to ease people into into
the game different concepts on my
tutorials I try to throw at you at once
like oh like seven different community
boards that actually matters do the
assist rock them down so you can perform
other actions
[Music]
because you're gonna better yeah
all these tiny characters fighting you
colors
you're supposed to die why you got it
yes that is correct sorry I mean Vanya
so she is 1 million percent official I
think that's really cool too
and I even though this dragon balls been
out for a long time the story is
obviously well known by a lot of people
but there's still new content in this
game that's still Canon that's pretty
cool
dang you almost did not it's like that's
the one thing jae-won that I was really
really upset with was if you get stunned
God he's the goofiest here comes he has
to be like one of my
five you're in that tougher than you
he's like stereotypical like big doofus
character we're like big and strong
Braulio says I don't know but when I see
the Hellfire if it makes me remember
kingdom heart a little bit
[Music]
is this an open-world game not
technically pretty much a little bit you
have side quests you can explore around
you don't have to necessarily you know
main line of camp time it feels open
world to me I don't know what like I
think technicalities safe
they tried not see you say with open
world but every map is pretty big yeah
and you can like open they move about
right so you know I would say it it is
also kind of like Kingdom Hearts where
you go to each world and then there's
all this stuff yeah yeah but well it's
not technically open-world it's pretty
much
if he says please tell me this game has
some sort of difficulty to it it looks
very easy that's just the pro like
you're gonna in the beginning it's gonna
feel easy as hell and in the middle of
some of these fights it's gonna feel
easy as hell and then I promise you like
the first main and boss fight with like
radix the curve gets drastically harder
all of a sudden and how easy your heart
the game is is really dependent on your
like any RPGs you can always over level
and then they'll be super easy
my preferred tactics but if you are a
masochist you got always go into it
under level through the bag right go
like this fight I think I'm without
level what's the max level
how do the controls feel not so great at
first and then once you get the hang of
it it feels better but this is like if
you played other Dragon Ball games like
budokai Tenkaichi or even like busy no
verse games it like I don't know if I
wish I could remap the buttons a little
bit sometimes to be honest but like once
you get the
it's really exhilarating
I guess Matthew we are playing on the
controller you're playing on the Xbox
wow that pose strike a pose simply
magnificent I must admit I'm impressed
you were able to gather all seven
dragonballs I'm surprised here it's
finally time to turn my dream of
immortality into a reality let's begin
shall we
Dragon Balls is it out some sort of
secret phrase no I think I'll ask myself
didn't you
you understood Lord Frieza I gotta fight
kidding you cuz I want to fight Frieza
I'm on a mission man someone in Chad
asked is the single player multiplayer
single-player its single-player only
there's
although someone mentioned earlier that
on the steam page it says multiplayer I
not sure if that's a mistake or what but
as far as we know and so far there is no
multiplayer you have the box right here
yep single-player mode solo confirmed
please be alive you guys please be safe
there are many games in here which
actually gives me a pile of minigames
[Music]
and krillen they're in trouble I miss
when they used to put booklets inside of
games mm-hmm they're really close right
where those three huge powers are nammed
I was so off one of this game release
tomorrow's tomorrow or today here on the
west coast yeah
the official release date January 17th
2020
let's go go through there you are um yes
this is an ITV Isaac's got a good point
you know it looks fun but the last thing
you want to do is play an RPG for
storylines you've seen a million times
this story has been replayed adapt every
single Dragon Ball and as we've done
this story a million times but that's
kind of the charm like look at this this
is so badass like Goku steps in front of
his kid that and they did say they've
expanded some backstory is a little bit
in this game like exclusively so there
will be some tidbits that will be new or
expanded upon but you might not have
seen before right and then like if
you're a fan you're gonna you're gonna
enjoy it you know anyway like it's this
is right up your alley ways it's kind of
like me and like Lord of the Rings is
being remade right now for with Amazon
Prime become imma be - yeah exactly
I would say since they are doing like
all of the main arts I have no doubt
that they have so many DLC options plan
to the future with all of the other arts
or you know they have so much to pull
from like why not
it's so weird I think like okay I'm on I
was in the different perform so he's
kind of weird I like this
there is no way to change the difficulty
is pretty straightforward but obviously
the difficulty will depend on what level
you are
this is weird I think there might be
like if you hit you with something
that's like moving you in he blasts only
again yeah
huh that's so weird yeah
so I'm just gonna be coming humming on
the entire
what are the achievements like a
skateboard
[Laughter]
oh dang
my power oh you're hurting now it
doesn't help
[Music]
well maybe the guy it'll stop the good
yeah
[Music]
got some drink oh my god Riku I'm gonna
absolutely destroy you
hey Chad you want to see rage David
put this man in the ground David give
the dirt that David I was scared for you
hard Jim yeah that my first be in the
game dear I'm so irritated Wow just mid
fighting just glitch meows like
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
his butt
sorry you were wide open so I just went
for oh my goodness raccoon have some
decency
they're children watching that's for is
in this fast-forwarding this give me
freeze up oh you guys want some I think
my health carries over this
[Music]
if that real quick thing is a 2v1 you
know what guys
check this is the real boss right now
can I can I do a 2v1
okay guys you're talking about
difficulty level this is like a kid do
get down to one health bar and then go
into the next yes if he is like well
that answers the difficulty question I
think it's so fun being voice actor
except for one year
yeah I'm better start screaming
they only have four more life bars for
you to take down each no big deal
[Music]
not like this
not looking good for right here that's a
life barb easy
[Music]
oh my god
oh yeah
oh my goodness
okay he's almost dead okay one more one
more
oh no he's he'll part yeah exactly
no no big deal you got six days week I'm
trying to be it to Friday
[Music]
oh yeah get it stay on the moon no we
don't want none of that
good stop why you with your face the
rocky technic is not a good idea right
now you really can't even afford to
block anything now it seriously stop
4600 at one else right now you got this
I believe
you're getting there slowly but surely
okay sorry about this that was
terrifying oh my god I'm a mess today
guys oh thank you for sending us your
energy yes Thank You Chad thanks
why would you let them get away with
that you may have grown stronger yes
y'all's energy made that happen
you had like literally a thousand health
left it was very cool huh yeah you guys
are the [ __ ] best thank you armored
attack I was like hey we haven't even
got free last night was good enough
though like that was entertaining for
you guys let's go let's go let's go
let's go come on Vegeta you got to work
together
experience so when you level up to your
your health and Yuki just we said
automatically yeah so if I didn't have I
didn't level up at that fight I would
have had said well yeah and that was a
battle
yeah I need this game all right let's go
again you owe
well you guys are at the same level and
you're fighting to again at least like
yeah bobbins Vegeta definitely nope
right out of it
and water
I know guys guys guys
buf
whoops yeah you can be careful
visualization last baby
dude the Australian guy that's like
picking away at you from a distance my
cat said he said something like talents
can you build characters different by
addressing are you talking about the
ability to have a maxim or bility at a
time but you definitely know so you can
like you can on make yours like let's
say to the people on your support party
you can have their attacks be more like
melee base base
things like that for sure but otherwise
it's like the builds are there they're
not experience said something that I was
literally thinking and game theory can
energy blogs work underwater like we're
like shooting fireballs are you sure I'm
down with that
[Music]
oh yeah easy
tater tooth says they're actually plasma
bat blasts of cry still work underwater
plasma what's wrong with me something
about that too I have no idea what you
guys are talking about like I am done
with his let's move on I like that a
nice progression the brick oome glitch
got me my first B and then that second
fight was kind of do you know can use a
like personality so I'm gonna skip this
too but basically what you does is he
changes bodies with with people so he
changed he changed bodies with Goku like
I'm oh so that's way greetings and
salutations yeah which is I suggest you
leave yeah we get out of here Fraser ah
to get out of here
all right you guys don't any beam
struggles yet no there haven't been any
light beam struggles or like button
mashing 50 beams happened but I think
there is um I think it is though in the
game I just haven't liked but I remember
specifically something with that and
like one of the tutorials
during the combat why you skip the movie
because we're trying to get to freeze
I'm sorry before the end of the stream
which is like minutes from now or so
yeah but we are gonna have full
playthroughs of this game up on YouTube
very very very soon yes so you guys will
be able to watch all of that good stuff
but you know our goal of this stream
with the fight for you always given
everything that's why sorry guys if you
uh if you're upset take it out on me
just follow me on Twitter so yeah it's
all it's all
a rumba appeal oh my god it's like
pieces away off gathering all of them
but they don't know how to use a sounds
like you're trying to explain to my mom
it does get a little complicated yet so
it confusing I felt like reading some of
the chat from yesterday stream most you
guys are familiar with the story so
hopefully it's not too much of an issue
you guys can actually 5/7 road you can
you're not my real dad that's my real
dad in this weird purple brains I'm
saying we don't really use phones as
long as my mind is separated from it you
can't unleash the full power it's like
having the power of heart or something
my true heart will shine through Jesus
that's trying to traumatize this boy's
childhood make him fight his father yeah
it's not as real dad though yo it still
gotta be mentally taxing
sometimes already grown up so much
before I going from not wanting to fight
to fighting his phantom father oh yeah
not being able to like pickles on apples
get to its this support character is
fine though
oh you're right I gotta use that more
often now
yeah did it go
I think there is probably still a good
amount of super weapons in my show up
here pop question in the chat okay I was
the only because I feel like from Elias
for me personally a lot of the classic
anime that were really really good and I
know they're great they have so many
episodes it's like daunting to go back
in and catch up on it
sure sure sure I'm not gonna like a lot
of people feel that way absolutely
cuz I also saw that seeing me about like
one piece I want to watch it but there's
so many others but that's why this games
for like all the catching up you need
and interact is there new gameplay oh
yeah can also be played in 4k
says it on the box yeah someone knows
the difficulty levels are in the
beginning of the game not that difficult
like there is no easy normal or heart
because it's all like level base but
it's it's easy as hell be together
experience asks by any chance would you
be able to play with the villains later
on I don't know if anyone knows yet um
as far as I know you only play is like
well I guess there's not really sure
what's so pretty early
yeah we just got copies of the game
literally yes like in the afternoon HDR
q it says ultra HP
all right dad
[Applause]
get out of here fake dad you're not even
my real dad basically do you know the
level before you fight if you're not at
a level do you get to go off and grind
are you locked until you beat you're not
locked leave indeed you're not locked to
me but you also don't necessarily know
their level the only levels you do know
are of people out in free play although
actually I think you could before you
trigger the event you can live a you
know use your obtain powers and like
measure people's keys which is they're
lovely so we'll have to see
I'll test it out before I joined the
next fight or whatever reason starts
making Appeals slaps the planet this bad
boy is weak will master yeah can you get
out of here thank goodness how do you
switch places with Vegeta we're all done
for
I'll give this part yeah someone say
jump skip this part I'm gonna keep this
- yeah it's funny I was like what is
this random frog got to do with this but
now it all makes sense
that is amazing oh my gosh his regular
body paint exactly oh the Frog is in
three earlier oh man I musta missed that
part
I actually sued Guinea to get my body
back to use the Dragon Balls I may not
be able to kill that rocky throws
greater than the speed of light
Charmeleon shows island Nara 2 story
through the game that's me and Dragon
Ball pretty much
he's remembering he's remembering he's
about to get rekt they could have all
been defeated
Miss Universe stands people have never
seen an anime I have I've started I mean
honestly I'm enjoying this because I am
getting a chance to like learn more
about it because I feel like the few
episodes I've seen is not from this part
of anomie right I guess the ones I've
seen are the Tournament of Champions
episodes which only a few I didn't see
all of them but I'm assuming that's much
further past this part of the story I
mean yeah but when you saw it was
probably that boosts wiping out universe
out onto him on because he asked for it
Ryu you started when do I see I actually
like the Buu saga and I mean I was glad
I kind of started that cuz I don't know
if I would have been attached to go on
as much as I am now if I didn't see him
like as an adult first I love how
they're just not acting like Vegeta
didn't just try to murder all of them
you know living let go or what I mean
yeah I really Kevin Smith who says I
know the episodes are amazing but
there's so many places to start that
it's overwhelming and the fact I can
enjoy it through a game - I definitely
feel the exact same way well we finally
collected the Dragon Balls no we thought
we'd had to guru's place and ask him
what to do this grand elder guru told me
to find you - you won't be able to make
a wish unless you say it in the namekian
language I wish we'd known that earlier
we have like all this power in front of
them just like he's probably still
sleeping we gotta make sure I said now
my saga is the best freezes the best
villain on the show
best villain yeah probably I am actually
do remember seeing like maybe one or two
episodes at a friend's house because I
distinctly remember Frieza counting to a
hundred but I thought those stupidest
thing but it was also kind of scary it
was weird resist freezes a creep I mean
[Music]
he turned gold oh I don't know when that
was like I've seen bits and pieces I
just have not gone in like from
beginning to end yeah it's a lot
the dragonballs on earth
what up greatness welcome to the shat
welcome to the stream oh wait how I
remember him looking well this is cell
saga is the best for teen gohan oh wait
you get more than one wish you get three
wishes yeah oh okay okay I thought it
was only one wish I think okay that is
such an earth thing to be of course we
only get one wish of course oh okay okay
there's some rules can't make anyone
fall in love with you three wishes I
just watched a live action last night so
it's a night it's fresh in my mind
yeah there's four of them
Piccolo's like bro you don't take me out
first and bring me back to life
oh it's a fight in heaven arena use it
to bring me back if I'm back then Tommy
will be as well how smart you have to
trust me on this
we can use the dragonballs on earth to
resurrect everybody else we can bring
them back that piccolo smart yeah right
I totally forgot about that and as for
the second wish you have to make him
send me to Namak I want to make that
wretched Frieza suffer slowly for
slaughtering my people yeah there you go
crazily thank you like if you're never
into the DBZ with the speak it's
starting cuz I heard they cut out filler
and kept it down to like main stories
that I know among the hardcore people
Dragon Ball Z Kai isn't looked upon too
well sometimes because they like just
remind a lot of stuff but if you were if
you wanted to get into dragons II I
would say that would wouldn't be a bad
place to start because it does there is
a lot of filler and if you're not a fan
of filler like you don't want to quite
investment in that world by all means
just play this game or
or watch Kai I bet you people out there
that speak their language that's crazy
so this is Planet Namek I'm on East
Coast will I be able to play the game
today no you're gonna play it at
midnight can you play in Japanese with
subtitles you can we're recording right
now so to keep it consistent we do it
with weight he granted our wish
then where's piccolo well you did ask to
have him sent to this planet but but you
didn't say where dang the text account
here yeah you idiot tell me 10 days
oh boy well we did until homeboy Jolie
mess it up
Matthew Kraus is I live in Central and
seam says it's going to unlock to play
in less than two hours it might be a
preload installation hey hold on y'all I
like how you have to give him your wish
in the language but he's speaking to you
in English okay yes Freeza has no hope
of beating me now even if I don't have
the strength to beat him I'll eventually
wear him down one way today okay here
goes
[Music]
the Dragons disappeared
guru snooze he's gone he finally died
sorry oh here we go
Frieza this storyline is sending me it
really you've really done it now haven't
you
you have destroyed my dream of Italian
immortality in the most spectacular
fashion as for the lack of response from
the guinea fella his little reader cuz I
suppose I have you brought that hmm I
don't fully understand what has happened
but this is a rather surprising turn of
events how could I have foreseen the
Dragon Balls turning to stone just as I
was about to make my wish a reality I
can only imagine Vegeta's disappointment
those pales in comparison to my own okay
this is a first to be sure no one has
ever been foolish enough to make a
mockery of me on such a grand scale all
right come at me bro so small so angry
no way we can beat someone like this of
course did you really think three measly
ads could defeat a dinosaur you just
call this ad I grow tired of hearing
about that preposterous myth please you
are no Super Saiyan I will say if you
are ever in a rush I'm like don't play
or what they drag things out so much
because they have to let you know that
they can transform a small number of
people throughout the universe have the
ability to transform when needed
some camouflage themselves with what
other beings use it to conserve their
energy
my transformation serves another purpose
I'm afraid you see my power is so great
that I struggle to contain it at times
what did you just say don't make us
Krillin are you dead you think so
you know I recall when I took over
planet Vegeta I hadn't a need to
transform in order to subdue you simian
barbarians and your king
that's right Vegeta your planet was
nothing special not even your father on
that rose
[Music]
Freeza disrespectful he's uh he's taller
now he's gonna have multiple
transformations the reason that you
probably knows what he's like bald right
yeah yeah he doesn't have horns like
welding yeah sorry we had to jump for it
but we must get this right in there yeah
we got officially but it doesn't matter
we're gonna keep this fight going
Eagle says oh no the one way Larry Larry
he transformed apparently I will say if
you upgrade your character the one thing
I would really look into its upgrading
your key levels because that stuff runs
out
I know it's like he's laying it out
you're right Jesus
yeah that was free even though we didn't
get in there that's the past master sick
you are no match for me oh no youth look
at it I mean it's there's like fighting
but I wanted to get at least one fight
in there for you guys we're trying to
aim for oh boy those nearby energies you
guys oh wait so are we going back to
fighting more or is there gonna be
another little spin-off here before we
get back so we'll say if we if we can
fight them right away then you maybe but
if it's gonna be got him as a sole
emblem though gotcha
the most electric fight had it be that
thank you guys for tuning in
I hope you enjoyed it like we mentioned
earlier we're gonna have full walk
throughs up on our channel very very
soon I know we skipped through some of
the story but we just wanted to show up
somewhere the fight scenes for you guys
yeah but if you want to see the full
thing it'd just be on the lookout for
those walkthroughs coming soon and of
course every weekday here at 11 a.m. is
when we go live with various games
luckily enough for us we got our hands
on Kakarot early and rabl extreme it for
you but we play a variety of things
every single days feel free to come on
back
we hope you had fun have a great day
happy Thursday one more day till Friday
you're almost there
but yeah take care and we will see you
guys later peace out
you